was your name Jennifer no its tenifer
with two y's it used to be Jennifer but
then I decided to rebrand myself oh wait
hang on it's an X o'clock um well nice
to meet you my name is April and I just
wanted to say that your dress is so cute
it's bungs it's on my spinning
instructor wearing it and I was like
shut up where do I get that oh my god
who's your spinning instructor Gregory
or Winona I go to Yanis who are Gregory
and Winona I've never heard of them
before are they better Winona
rocks my world seriously you need to get
me in there like that's a must must must
she's the worst person I've ever met I
want to travel the world with her you
want her to see me sir
I understand you stopped by the patrol
offices morning briefing yeah officer
deetmore helped me out with my crime
scene so I gave him a little thank-you
present hey deetmore you're gonna bag
evidence like a five-year-old you should
have the proper tools - my first police
kit the walkie talkie blows bubbles hope
you can handle it he mislabeled the
weapon like an idiot
and it almost got filed with the wrong
case he could've won months of work you
humiliated officer deetmore in front of
his peers he submitted an official
complaint against you did you feel it on
crayon no but he did use a green pen
which seems crazy to me the good news is
if you go down there and apologize you
let the whole thing go fine I'm great at
apologizing I'm a very sweet person
out of my way chunk oh babe you look
more beautiful right now than I have
ever seen you Wow just your luck that
you're going into labor on Halloween can
I get a warm towel to get that makeup
off no I went it on that's the whole
point I put the makeup on after I went
into labor whatever blows your skirt up
okay are you ready to push wait no babe
my birth makes
here comes a contraction are you ready
okay I'm ready let's do this graveyards
five what about this guy no he was
scared of everything do you remember
roses reaction last time the printer
jammed pay for that what's your endgame
here my dear this is only temporary
until I find a way to keep the shelter
open without cutting the parks budget
hey what if I threw together a pet
adoption and in one of our parks would
that be cool
April that would be the coolest thing
since insync Aerosmith and Nelly
performed together at the Super Bowl
halftime show no I think I may have
found a project I'd actually enjoy doing
helping these cats and dogs they should
be rewarded for not being people I hate
people all right Gina
we have to act soon that cold medicine
Diaz chugged it was the non-drowsy kind
she's all over the place I got a new
lead that's my firm about this is drug
dealer on State Street
hello no there's no Michael here you're
the wrong number goodbye
I'm Michael that's a dumb name but it's
yours and you should be proud of it
because you are the greatest detective
I've ever known
no doy yes no doy she's so hopped up on
that stuff her brain's gonna blow I'm
gonna interrogate the perp you keep Diaz
occupied I don't want to get near her
germ face permission to lock her in a
distant room no just distract her yes
that is what I will do Reza
I gotta tell you something as a secret
okay well I have a lot of stuff to do
everything okay with Diaz yeah she fell
asleep five minutes after I locked her
in and she hasn't moved in the past ten
hours she talks in her sleep rip your
damn head off grandma you know what I'm
gonna get that commission going because
this inequality has gone on long enough
you know what I think men are better
than women she's kidding no I'm not they
provide for us and we must obey them
because they are our masters April stop
it Leslie
you'll never land a bow with that
domineering tone we must always walk
behind the man that's a pee-eww portable
ultrasonic weapon it emits a focused
beam of sound which can disorient and
even incapacitate a purple so shoot
sound mmm
is this a trigger yes but you want to be
careful again thought it would be louder
it's highly directional we're pointed at
you you'd be in incredible pain right
now
[Music]
my thoughts so I long for a day when
women in government will simply be seen
as people in government but until then I
will work to make Pawnee my wonderful
hometown as good as it can be what do
you think I think you should lose the
first line and the last line and all of
the other lines and instead just walk up
to the mic and meow really loudly for
eight minutes
okay Peralta what the hell where were
you I got eliminated excuse me officer
yes sweetheart sweetheart seriously Hank
is how you talk to women who come in
here Jimmy jabs I didn't make it past
one person okay so I took extensive
notes on ways to maximize our efficiency
because we can't be just as good as the
men we have to be better yeah you're
totally right let's rock this April I
love you but I don't need your sarcasm
right now and I'm serious let's get
rolling I want to get into some garbage
what I love garbage you ever found a
dead body in the trash we're body parts
like a torso or a head please say a head
[Music]
this is Stacy nah blocks house I went to
high school with her and she was super
mean to me and now I know that she dyes
her hair
I knew that wedge wasn't naturally
blonde oh my god she has to use
prescription strength deodorant this is
the best day of my life anymore I'm
sorry for making fun of you in front of
everybody and also for making fun of you
behind your back didn't know you did
that but thank you for the apology
I'm not done also I'm sorry for making
fun of you during my book club those
people don't even know you that was
uncool also I'm sorry it's okay I get it
no also I'm sorry that I didn't take the
time to show you how to fix your mistake
come on we can go over to upstairs
Thanks it'll be great oh one more sorry
you're about to see a drawing I did of
you in the elevator just remember I was
really pissed at the time
so you do a lot of investing we like to
dabble mm-hmm I recently invested in
some shirts I got at a garage sale left
those at Wendy's on the way home the
economy only had our low for a day and a
half but if anything happened to him I
would kill everyone in this room and
then myself very violent eulogy I like
it I don't know my Leslie knope's on
trial like a baby's dead I see the color
blue and yellow and I see the letter L R
s TW e and B so basically everyone's
first date guess is in hangman Thank You
Carlene your entire life is garbage new
part-time job in the public health
department at City Hall and Meredith
Perkins yay well Leslie this is so nice
I put the poisonous gas in one of these
balloons so if any of them pops he may
die okay no problem
okay all right my babysitter's busy the
night of Boyle's wedding she's gonna be
in her high school talent show which
he's gonna lose unless her talent is
leaving potato chip crumbs all over
Terry's couch wait Boyle set a date
already hey he gave up saved two days
yesterday you ain't give you he's been
avoiding me you didn't invite me to his
wedding and he's scared like a little
[ __ ] well maybe Vivian was
uncomfortable with you coming but boy
was in love with you until a few weeks
ago oh don't be angry I'm not angry I
think it's funny
[Laughter]
so you're from Mongolia Dean will you
take me with you and you go back there
Oh bleep I love you did you understand
that did you bring any Wolverines look
what I found in Hitchcock and Scully's
trash can ice cream spoon
[ __ ] you Hungry Hungry Hippos ate my
ice cream why was this in your trash and
who throws away a spoon it's the easiest
utensil to clean I don't even think it's
ice cream it's probably medicine you
know I'm on lots of medicines Rosa I'm
sick all over this is ice cream and I'm
gonna prove it Sarge
no it's been in their mouths well I
guess your little investigations hit a
dead end
I'll be back till much not a problem
I hate moving there to go
you